Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Clustered.
This is episode three of Clustered Teams, and
we have two wonderful teams joining us today.
We have team Skyscanner
and team DigitalOcean.
Now before we introduce them and get started
today, there's just a little bit of housekeeping.
Firstly, I wanna thank Teleport for sponsoring Cussert.
Teleport is a product that we have used
on this show since the very first episode
even before they sponsored us. I think it's
a fantastic product. You're gonna see it in
action today as we debug these two broken
clusters, and you should check it out for
yourself by checking out rawcode.liveteleport.
Also, you should subscribe to this channel. There's
lots more content
focused on cloud native Kubernetes and everything in
between.
It is a vast cloud native landscape, and
I hope that these videos will help you
navigate it and all learn together.
We also have a Discord server available at
Rawkode.chat,
so come on, say hello.
There's over 400 and something odd of us
in there now chatting, so I look forward
to meeting you.
Alright. Let's get started with today's first team.
I am joined by team Skyscanner.
Hello, team Skyscanner. How are you?
Hello. Good. Thanks. You?
I mean, I don't need to fix cluster,
so I'm feeling pretty great. How are you
feeling, Guy?
Moderately
terrified.
Well, you should be because I'm sure people
might remember your little voice and your smirky
attitude as you broke a cluster for me
previously with a Unicode character. Not that I'm
better, but, you know I I I feel
I was appropriately apologetic
about it.
No. It's an absolute pleasure to have you,
and I'm really excited to see you work
on this cluster together. Can we start with
our round of introductions,
please? We'll start with you, Guy.
Sure.
Yep. I'm
Guy Tempton. I am a software engineer at
Skyscanner,
where I'm,
partly responsible for
the,
shared container platforms that we run,
the website on.
Outside of that, I'm also,
one of the co chairs of SIG Auto
Scaling for Kubernetes.
So,
please feel free to come and harass me
if you think auto scaling in Kubernetes doesn't
work the way it should.
Okay. Matthew?
Okay.
Hi, everyone. My name is Mateo Rina.
I'm a software engineer at ScanScanner. Been here
for four years enough now, and I've been
working with Guy and Alex
for such a long time. I
work as well on the container platform
and recently focus on on deployment
where we are doing some open source work
around application set and to
to release
a progressive sync controller. So if you're interested,
please come come to me.
We're trying to to scale the tops for
our needs,
and I love to hear your opinion.
The good news is it loaded. The bad
news is I only see two machines.
I'm
gonna open a session on our control plane
node. Please, if you could join the session,
we'll keep an eye on the number in
the top left, but feel free to type
an echo hello to let us know that
you are in.
And we've got one, two,
one more to go.
Oh, there we go. Perfect.
Awesome. Supposed to be fine.
Alright. Well, this is a QBDM cluster, so
you will have to export your cube config.
And I suggest you check for a control
plan and take it away. Best of luck.
Okay. Do you wanna steer the first
obstacles?
Sure.
I found that in the comments someone says
someone broke telephone again,
we really
have a lot of the previous episodes.
There's What a surprise.
There's there's rule, people. I mean, come on.
It's not as hard. But yeah.
K. We've got a connection refused. Did we
specify the right host report?
I mean, just can
can you add the prompt?
That's that'd be really that'd be really cheeky,
but I think it should be fine. Maybe
it's just pointing to something something DigitalOcean,
though.
K.
I don't see a cluster.
This is Yeah. Context. Is it off? Or
is the Maybe maybe don't open it.
There is no case. Oh,
there you go.
Where's the scroll?
Yeah.
Yeah. As the scroll goes, just give the
window a little jiggle.
There we go. That's an x term JS
bug.
Hoping someone's gonna fix it one day.
Is that right URL
on the server? Yeah. Hopefully, the right IP
address. Should we check should we check if
we've actually got a kubelet running and containers?
Yeah.
In the run to this, I've had to
learn
container d.
We
do have a kubelet.
Is it happy with?
We're getting nodes.
Okay.
And
let's check for the manifests.
We do have a Kube API server in
there.
Let's get to our controller manager.
Alright. Here's here's the question. Can I remember
how to use container d runtime?
Minus n indicates the idle. Yeah.
And then c l Containers.
C for short.
Okay.
So we have a cube scheduler. We have
a cube controller manager, and we do have
a cube API server.
So
maybe we want to have a look at
what the
config of the API server is.
Sorry. Say,
we were happy with the API that we
have in the admin on call with with
the IP address.
That's know the universe of this now.
That is a good point.
Yeah. So there is a server
yes. So that URL is what it's supposed
to be. Shouldn't be
localhost.
If we only add the chance to access
another cluster and look at the keep it
all together.
Oh, yeah.
Guess I can't
remember. So right now you're trying to you're
you're speculating that potentially the modified IP address
in that file. Okay. So you're gonna wanna
check the IP a d d r on
the look back interface. That is where the
BGP advertised EIP is
or the control plane.
IP I should check it.
D d r.
Space a d d r. Yeah.
You must do IS config. This should get
you some It was being deprecated twenty five
years ago.
Still
works, though. So this is your
BGP advertised address here, 1477580Dot168.
That should be your control plan.
K. It's right in memory.
Yeah. I think that is.
Server?
147758168.
Looks good.
Okay.
K.
So that's working.
That that's not that's not wrong. Sorry.
The chat thinks it's DNS, but I think
they're trolling me. I
think they might be, and I totally
deserve it.
Okay. So what was the what what error
message were we getting again?
Collection refused.
It's trying to go somewhere, but either it's
not listening. So maybe they're buying the port
for the API server?
Yeah. It is the the the Kubernetes config,
which is
in a config app, which you can't get
or someone on disk.
We can see what the Kubernetes server is
being run with, though.
If I remember to Greta.
Now
what you do, you shouldn't see that as
a service because it's a static part. Right?
Can you hear them?
Yeah. Yeah. It should still be
Used to a PS UXF.
I don't know if it's just there.
This is what we get for not really
Kubernetes. Yeah.
K. I'm gonna go ahead and raise a
ticket with the AWS and see what happens.
These
are bare metal clusters. Come on.
I mean, I'm gonna throw something out there,
but, you know, you haven't attempted to look
at the API server logs.
That is that's a
Very good point. Do
you know where they are?
No. We we we use docker. Proper proper
runtime.
Varlog containers.
Okay.
So
we have could you really keep it keep
API server?
The command you're looking for is tail.
Yeah. I was I was gonna go with
less, but
failed to find any pen data in the
key the key data. Nice.
TLS.
Is
that all it is?
That probably should have won a cubic in.
So we do have
key search.
So in one of the previous episode, there
there was a summary generating all the certificates
with Keyblade.
Maybe we can do the same.
You can indeed.
QMIDI and search. Search.
QMIDI
something something. Yeah? And I'm pretty sure that
the help the help the page with with
now as well. Search? Medium search
renew.
And
maybe there is, like, a old or something.
Yeah. There there is a renew.
Wait for it. All? Look
at that. We've never used a tool and
just guess the CLI.
We need it to get CLI.
There you go.
Okay.
Freshly minted certificates ready for your service.
So restart
Kubelet. I can never remember. If we restart
Kubelet, that won't necessarily bring back up the
restart all the
the pods, will it? The static pods too.
It says It won't because the container d
runtime is still
running. If I even restart now, it wouldn't
restart it. But it is a crashing static
pod, it will restart manually.
I'll just have a look at logs again,
see if it I guess I'm doing unless
it's crashing. That
one isn't That was three minutes ago.
Yeah. But
have we got a new one yet?
Just minus l on it.
Yeah. Yeah. And capital t, I think, the
time.
Not that. No.
Letter t.
So
I think I got a Steam 42,
but nothing
okay. So it's not immediately restarted.
I mean, you can modify the static manifest
to encourage it to be restarted about the
car.
Yeah. Looking at the manifest of the
this is the manifest.
So
I mean, on the basis of modify something.
Something people don't take advantage of, and it
shows the
them remembering the cursor from the last edit.
That's that's a nice hint.
How how how far did I move it?
You weren't paying attention. I wasn't.
Feels like it might have been around the
port.
Yeah.
You should check for logs. That's there should
be Yeah. There should be something there. Yeah.
The Vim thing's always funny.
So
I can't remember what time. Here we go.
Chat is surprisingly quiet. They're normally in there
with all the advice.
This
wow. This,
the scrolling issue happens on every on every
command. Yeah.
It's
it's an idea.
Now if we could all just make our
window the same size, it would go away.
Yeah. That'll that'll happen.
Okay. So we're still getting errors.
And that's it.
Connection refused.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Might have to restart that as well, which
is or look at the last one.
Yeah. So we'll look at the manifest or
the logs.
Where is It's on some chat bar log
pods as well. We
can indeed.
Nice.
The set.
K. So it looks
happy enough. Yeah. I I think that maybe
a two d restarting after the search has
been renewed.
Yeah.
And
the port was the right one.
Two three seven nine and Yeah. There it
said, 2379.
I mean, that's well, that's that's also now
a minute ago. So actually
Ta da. There
we go.
You have a control plane. We have two
unready nodes.
Try something. Canines.
Goodness.
I I I why not? Again, some encouragement
from the Digital Ocean team. Shahar is saying
you're doing great, smiley face. There you go.
The rest of the chat are just laughing.
I
don't blame them. Hey, Khalid.
I think I think the problem is we
are teaming with Guy and everyone remembers him
from the previous episode. So this is why
the chat is quiet and no one is
cheering. Yeah.
There's a there's a comment from Waleed saying
this is team unique, Khalid. So there you
go.
We're we're like a yeah. We're like a
friendlier.
You you see Oh, who stuck k nines
on this?
Just you just saw me do it. I'm
sorry. I was looking at the chat.
Oh, we've we've not had anyone bust out
k nines yet. That's nice.
You start seeing things that are nice and
red like that thing which we started a
lot. Yeah. Oh, and cheeky CDM as well.
That's the the new command from previous logs.
This is complaining.
I'm talking to the API server, unable to
Yeah. Communicate. Oh, turn on wrapping.
1477580.
I mean
I don't know the notes.
I I quite like if they click time
stamp time stamps on those
What's
the
Better policy?
Why? Everything happens.
So
what's the symptom you're seeing just now? Your
Celine pod can't reach
the Kubernetes API server?
Yeah. Think so. Yeah. So a few things
are where things are happening as well, but
a few things fail to find out.
Alita's asking, what is that tool? That is
canines.
You should check it out.
And
yeah. So if you hit the pods
one that's having problem on worker two. So
worker two seems to be our our next
problem.
I I mean, I guess the the question
is, our our aim is to upgrade the
app. Do we try it and see what
breaks? So
the problem is the Postgres is a worker
two. So unless we move it, we probably
need to talk to worker
two because otherwise
It's different. What's that? You're just so sneaky
guy. Like, we're not gonna fix the broken
thing. We're just gonna make the thing work,
which is a good strategy. A good strategy.
Okay. Yeah. What what are we trying to
achieve? We're trying to give, you know, the
the viewers access to your lovely new version
of the website. Yeah. That's that's the main
thing. We can come back and fix things
after.
I think that's why. First.
I don't see any
Level set. No API server connection.
Where?
In the bottom? See the the red Ah.
Yeah.
Do do do we have, like, a do
we have, like, a a network a network
role that does
random dropping or stuff and stuff like that?
Yeah. So that's why I was seeing here
when I was trying to
So last night, I had I had my
first look as a serial documentation,
and and they have something called network policy.
Yeah. Like You want to send that out?
But now it looks like we've had to
to go on, which means
That was a nice shout, though. Yeah. I
mean, that's what I would do.
We got a comment from someone called Spedge
who says he's very proud of you, guy.
Pointing hair manager likes likes the
being able to cite Skyscanner's
principles. Yeah. Let's pretend Skyscanner.com
is done. Come on, guy. Let's get this
thing fixed.
Get it fixed.
A comment from Noel saying, just schedule the
workload on the control plane nodes. Go for
it. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So, Michelle, should
we look at the logs again? The the
tailing of the API server. Yeah. Yeah. Because
if the end of the certificate expired again,
then maybe that is
Context
context deadline.
This is a time out. You just have
twenty minutes remaining.
That's fine. So that's it, Jean, that, like,
had a wee problem.
I'm gonna take over.
Received terminate signal.
From who?
From
who?
At,
yeah, five minutes ago, which is roughly when
we started seeing
weird things happen, and it started back up
again.
Tests for Rats again.
Mhmm.
Anything up there?
Oh, looks like it's got two members.
I need to make my
screen the exact same size as David.
Listen URLs.
It's got two IP addresses, but it's one
of them's public.
I'm gonna start using the command line,
teleport client, I think.
Anything obvious? The license.
Does it come here? Anything obvious?
No.
Key points to members local on private.
It's a hundred oh, the and is it
you killed?
Oh, do you see that?
Someone in chat said it's a hundred
megabytes of RAM.
I think it's the hundred milli cores on
the CPU.
I know. Know. I know.
Haven't profiled the SCD myself, so I'm not
sure if that is a good or a
bad value.
But I think it should be alright for
it to be, to be fair.
Maybe not.
How
how does
I
see things.
So we've got
Did it say, like, I don't want anything
about it?
No. It's just in the container.
This is to make sure I'm on the
right page. Do we have a working API
server at the moment?
Kind of Intermittently.
Yeah. Let's go and look at it as
a part then.
It's
If you don't see
we should see it. Does it run as
a static product, did it? Or does it
run?
It should be running as a static project.
Yeah.
And it should be visible in the cube
system namespace.
Yeah.
Okay. Okay. Should
we have a look at the cubelet logs
to see why it's not?
Yeah. There we go. Failed to create a
mirror pod for
no priority. No. Let's
I'm going sideways.
Go max prox.
Okay.
Content exceeded
for API server.
Connection refused
to the API server.
You you were using So is there yeah.
Is that
have they got an admission
webhook then?
Looks like it.
There is there is in the logs as
well.
So many people.
If if we can catch it whilst it's
up.
The admission rather yeah. Give it to TL.
I
mean, should should we set up the auto
complete whilst we're doing this as well? Because
I
did not trust myself to go, yeah, I've
typed that correctly so I could trust what
I've I've got back.
Yeah. Nice.
Yeah. That's a. And
you missed the API server window.
Yeah.
What's the difference here? Even
that? You just have fifteen minutes of fun
left.
So did we check if for the
if the what priority is in the manifest?
No.
You have to come.
I I I think Mateo has been confused
by that. Do you want to take over,
Mateo? Yeah.
Now I got you.
I was gonna sit down and wait.
Yeah.
It was it was about something something that
they were drinking. I was like, sure.
Is that what goes as well, brother?
Clarity class system not critical. Yeah. So
I was relaxed in the chair, so what
were we doing?
See
the visual webhooks.
Yeah. Billy from the Digital Ocean team has
said you're doing great. If you want a
hint,
just see.
Maybe
not yet.
Yeah. Let's let's see if we can
Have a look at the validating 1.2? Web
validating.
Yeah.
You're
gonna have to fix that
I said the API server. You you can't
debug without this.
Yep. Yeah.
So is it the API server that's restarting,
or is it at to do this restarting?
What times do we have if you run
a PSE UX?
What did you do for f?
Just
yeah.
It has
all of the
okay. Yeah. This whole process is a bit
scroll up. Oh, wait.
Just watched I may wanna just grab for
API server and and etcd.
In fact, there's the API server there.
So that's literally
just restarted.
Yep. And what about ETD? When did that
actually start?
Okay. It's not running. So Yeah. What
did you say in Cubelet, Guy? The I
missed it.
It was I was trying to post to
an API, and it was getting refused.
Was it paused?
So the API server is probably reboot because
the SCD is slapping. You're gonna wanna work
at SCD.
So if you have a look at the
the keyboard logs again, Matilde. It's just Yeah.
And then with controller.
So
if you have a look at,
there was
yeah. There's error syncing pods.
Error syncing pod failed to start container for
ICD with partial back off. Alright. There you
go. It's crashing.
We need to get into the STD logs,
I think. Yeah. Go have a look at
the logs. We we looked at them through
parts last time, but we can
This just gets a shutdown.
Yeah.
Do we have something sending this signal to
CD?
So this is gonna be probes. That's
my hunch.
Yes. It's it's getting a nice terminated signal.
So We should see that in the Qubelet
box.
Because the Qubelet controls it. So just grab
this for searches with.
Connection refused. Error syncing.
Question back.
Unable to write event.
You were hot earlier. Now we're cold.
Label to write the end. Does it mean
that there are there is no space?
Okay. So we have ten minutes left. So
I'm gonna throw something out there, and we
can ask for a hint if he's one.
But I would remove all the probes from
the static manifest and the resource limits. Like,
let's not give it any reason to shut
this part down.
Some of the cover?
Some I see. Manifest.
I'm just I think this point just
That that is that is a subtle way
to say that I was typing too slow.
Yeah.
I mean, not so subtle, but
Yeah. Remove the limits.
Yeah.
And remove the liveness.
Yeah. Just delete the whole file.
It's nothing important in there. Right? I mean,
those are just requests. So but you can
remove them anyway.
Start a probe. I'd remove remove the start
a probe as well. Sublime is all
And if anything past commit is on 16,
thank you very much.
And should we save this? Cool.
Coming from Rawkode's in Rawkode's smash. Yeah. I'm
not as subtle or elegant with some of
my effects. That is
you've gotta rule out
anything that you think could be getting in
the way again as effects. Right? You mean
you can add back probes later. You can
add back resource limits later. Yeah. Really, you
just need a working entity.
You wanna check those?
Let's see those entity logs.
Okay.
It won't be two twenty anymore, though.
Won't even do this thing anymore.
Probably just because the pod ID has changed.
Use firewall containers. That way you don't have
to worry about the
directory changing.
Okay. That is a healthy entity
Yeah. For for now.
They
are namespaced as well, remember.
Dash dash all namespaces like an absolute monster.
We've taken that. That's
working on the I think it failed.
It's still there.
Ta da.
That looks suspicious.
Now you gotta look at it or delete
it? Curious.
You gotta look.
I got my boss.
Nice. They did.
I create pods
star. It went to a
object
selector
just for
this.
Alright. Remember your mission. You got seven minutes.
K. So if the question's looking slightly healthier,
I'm not overly happy
with that. But No.
Let's think first is to
this.
Anything
else?
And it already failed, but we'll try that
first.
Nothing within container creating.
Mhmm. It's pulling the image. Yeah. There you
go.
But can't does it work?
Would you like me to try?
Give it a shot. Yeah.
Why not? So it's exposed via teleport, and
we can click custard.
That's the successful one. Mission successful.
No. I think you still got a particularly
broken cluster,
but
you did manage to deploy an update to
your application and browse to it. So well
done, team Skyscanner.
It's eventually consistent.
How was that? You enjoy that?
Yeah. It's good for me. There's some tricky
ones in there.
I I think as always, the most
irritating ones are the intermittent ones where you
go, okay. Go on to the oh god.
No. No. Still broken.
Alright. So now you know what you've fixed
and you know what you've broken. Who who's
meaner?
I think we we might be meaner. Alright.
We're dying. So
Well, you don't keep my reputation up.
I
don't think it's up, but whatever, Guy. No.
It was a pleasure. Thank you, Guy. Thank
you, Matthew. Thank you, Alex. I hope you
enjoyed that. Please feel free to watch from
YouTube, be in the chat if you're available.
I'm gonna invite Digital Ocean to come and
join the session, and I will jump back
over to here for just a moment. So
thank you. I'll speak to you soon.
Alrighty. So while we wait for Digital Ocean,
I would remind you all to like, subscribe,
and click that bell, and another awesome thank
you to Teleport for sponsoring Clustard.
They made this show possible with their support.
We use the product. We love the product.
You should check it out too.
Run Teleport on your infrastructure to commoditize access
through secure protocols,
remote pairing. Right? That's pretty cool.
And application
proxy in as well. Okay. We've got,
I've still got to kick them out. Skyscanner
just hanging around.
Definitely outstaying their welcome.
Welcome, Shahar.
Oh, it's got that's your team coming in
there. There we go.
Welcome, Billy,
Jeremy,
and one more.
So this then affects everything. Right?
So the the they they kinda fix it,
but they worked around the STD problem.
Right? So, like, it I did the same
STD thing I did last time where I
just changed the the liveness probe to be
health c instead of health so it would
crash every two and a half minutes and
then be down for a while. And I
noticed it because your Vim cursor started there.
I even gave them the hint, but they
they they didn't they didn't take it. Yep.
Alright.
Wait. There there was there the the validate
emission or the the mutating emission webhook would
have all
all it did was it changed the v
two tag to v one. So they would
have changed it in the deployment and then
the pod still would have been running v
one even though the deployment had been changed.
Sneaky. I like that. Definitely cool.
You could do some serious amount of damage
with those mutating and webhooks. Right? And you
have no visibility into what's happening, which is
which makes it even painful to debug.
Yeah. I have another idea for doing the
same kind of thing, but without without without
without a mutating webhook.
You keep that to yourself for now if
we can bring that one.
We're still missing one person.
Colin. Colin.
Alright. Let's get you hooked up with teleport.
Oh, no. We haven't done introductions. I'm so
rude. Apologies.
Let's start with a a quick round of
introductions, and hopefully, Colin will join us, but
we'll let him see oh, there we go.
Perfect.
Welcome back. Alright. So
Alright. Can we do introductions?
We just
take it away.
Shahar, do you wanna go first since you're
top right, then just loop around.
Yeah.
Hi. I'm Shahar. I'm a software engineer at
DigitalOcean working on the app platform.
And, yeah, excited to be here.
Billy, you wanna go next?
Sure. I'm Billy Kleeck. I'm a staff engineer
at DigitalOcean.
I've been doing Kubernetes stuff for almost four
years,
running internal platforms at deal that that host
the vast majority of our internal services.
Jeremy, you're you're you're next on my screen.
Hi, everyone. My name is Jeremy Morris. I'm
a software engineer.
I primarily work on DOKS.
That's DigitalOcean's managed Kubernetes product.
Hello. Hi. My name is Colin. I I
work with Jeremy on the containers
team, primarily
focused on the the registry product right now,
hoping to get into Kubernetes more later.
Awesome. Thank you all, and thank you for
joining us. That was a sneaky cluster. It's
now your turn to see what SkyClanner have
prepared for you.
So I'm gonna pop open my screen share.
I will open a session on the control
plane note
and if you can just let me know
when you're in there and ready and feel
free just to check for a control plane
when we get a after we've got a
few echo hellos.
Oh, we're missing a face. Let me get
that working.
There we go.
Okay. I see active sessions?
And you should be able to see, yep,
an active sessions.
Oh, no.
I mean, fresh.
I'm definitely a little nervous after after they
said that they're they think they're meaner than
us. I'm looking through some some of Guy's
previous breaks, so we'll see.
Yeah. I did swear I'd never have him
back on the the show. But Yep. That's
that's probably for the best.
Anyone that brings Unicode to clusterfight isn't good
in my book.
Alright. How are we getting on there?
We're still waiting. I might just tag along
then. I'm trying to, like Just to make
sure you're on Skyscanner.cluster.live
and not digitalocean.cluster.live.
Right?
Yes.
And you went you went to active set
you went to activity in active sessions
and joined the active session?
I I'm not able to
oh, I might not have oh, my bad.
I have not
set up correctly. That's on me.
Alright.
Sorry. Whenever you're ready.
If someone wants to take over and check
for a control play, we'll get this thing
underway. Best of luck, team Digital Ocean.
Alright, Jeremy. Are you you gonna drive?
Yeah. I'll start driving.
Alright. Let's get a let's first things set
up get set up config and and our
alias. I love that that alias is the
first thing even before the cube config. That
that's my kinda party.
Yep.
And then, tipped a bit for the auto
completion as well.
I don't remember that.
Do you wanna type that in? Yep. This
is still a lot. We can run this
command.
Yeah. I'll cut it.
There we go.
There we go. Cool. K. And
so
maybe look at the note or something.
Okay.
Wonderful.
There we go. So,
couple of things. Let's let's go check those
manifests.
First thing, Etsy Etsy Kubernetes manifest and just
let's see what the timestamps are.
What I love is that is an actual
response from the API server. That is not
that that is a working ish API server.
Oh, yeah. That's right. Yeah.
How do I get the oh, there yeah.
It's just time stamps.
Currently unable to handle the request.
Did you do export? You did.
Oh, boy. Okay. This is this is fun.
So
does does anything work? Can you do
k get pods?
K.
Okay. Let's check let's check let's check the
logs
for Kubelet.
How how do I click that?
Sweet journal CTL slash u kubelet
dash f.
Just follow follow them for a bit.
No. It'd be dash u kubla first.
Yeah.
K.
Second event.
Let's let's let's check to see if,
etcd is running.
We so component status is is not something
we can do for,
the controller and
but I I think it does social ID.
Right? Or is that not even used to
use at all at this point? I don't
I don't think we're gonna be able to
use,
cuckuddle at all for a little bit.
So let's let's just check to see whether
SED is running with PSAX
grab for SED.
Minutes.
K.
Alright. So
and can we check logs for
a etcd?
Etcd
or something like that?
I think we're gonna have to look at
the varlog containers to see them because
gets that TD is being run system d
as running as a static pod.
Yeah. So check check those
STD logs.
Yeah.
Checks
okay.
Okay.
That's interesting.
Okay. So we so we can we can
it looks like we can connect to Kube
Kube API server,
but it can't by the way.
I'm not sure what's up with that. But
Yeah. So there is a a small bug
in Xterm JS. If you can't scroll, you
just, like,
resize the window a millimeter. It just kinda
fixes it.
I know it's it it does get a
little bit frustrating, especially
as it breaks on my side and then
I do it. But eventually, we'll get something
that works.
I'll just resize it as needed.
Awesome.
Alright. So what should we do next?
Let let's just do a k get notes
again just to make sure that they didn't
do something like what we did where SEB
is crashing.
No. Okay.
Server is currently unable to handle the request.
Let's let's check QA API server logs.
That was the handle of the crash.
Failed the bot. Failed the list.
What's that top one? Failed
failing or missing response from?
Should that be six okay. Let's go check
that's interesting.
Oh, we can't check that. So is there,
like, a cluster role that that's for this?
Yeah.
Yep. So but
I don't I don't know how we would
check it without
without Kubernetes,
without without being able to
so but but let's try. Like, may maybe
maybe maybe you can see its own cluster
roles. So just do
k get cluster roles. Let's see what's there.
See if it'll tell us anything.
No. Nothing.
And do we do we do we have
a do we have a log that will
tell us about this in Kube API server?
So this this values pay that we just
did.
See the logs again. So we maybe it'll
give us some hint about what we just
failed.
That doesn't look recent.
It doesn't?
What time is it?
Yeah. It's not too bad. Jeremy,
was was that was that the end of
it, or was that
the This You did 10 end of it.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yep.
Good catch. I didn't notice that timestamp, but
that is indeed a loop. And
there's two of these these pods,
though, and we're
Yep.
Yeah. Could be like an underdog.
Agreed.
So wanna take a look at the other
one, Jeremy?
Yep.
So
not 40
Yeah.
That's the one.
There we go. Okay.
Alright.
So
data watch server is currently unable to repush
request in ESpace.
I will sync it right. Okay.
Let's go take a look at the the
QAPI server
manifest.
I think that's a good idea.
The the reason I'm doing that is is
up it says that the server is currently
unable to connect to
a it's currently unable to service the request.
So I'm wondering if
these IP addresses are
correct.
And I know that from looking at so
because I I did a little bit of
reconnaissance on since Guy had done this before
to go see what kinds of things he
had broken before.
Because I know I repeated some things, I
thought he might as well.
So secure port looks right.
We should probably check these
these IP ranges for
the services and for
what we're listening on. So I don't
think
I wanna take a look at the flags
here in just a minute too.
We resize the window again. Hold on. K.
There we go.
Alright. Let's
let's go up to the top here and
take a look at the flags that QAPI
server is running with.
Gonna go to the top again. Oh, okay.
Let's go down. Yeah.
So is that IP address for the advertised
address? Is that right?
I think so. How how do we check
that?
I think we'd have to take take a
look at the the IP addresses the the
virtual IPs that we have.
Is that the IP adder command?
Yep. That'd be something else. IP IP adder
l?
There we go.
Okay.
I think that's the same.
108046143.
I think that's right. Can can you can
you just double check
the the flags again? 108046143.
10 80.
Yep.
And is let's
because team
Unicode,
let's make sure that I oh, let's just
type that I IP address in.
I like it. What am I doing with
this?
We're just gonna retype. So it's 10 so
I just would go go to the equal
sign and just do an insert and put
that same IP address in, delete delete what
they had.
Oh, so just delete this and retype it?
Yes.
K. So it's
1080.
I don't remember it. 40 no. I think
it was 46143.
Jesus. Okay.
I mean, you could just do a slash
and search for that address and make sure
it matches as well.
But if you hit escape and then forward
slash and then search for 108046143.
And
then you can use n to make sure
it matches the one at the top, but
I think it will.
Press
enter and then press n.
And it's matching it to them all, so
I think you're good. Yep. I think so
too.
But but there if there if there's my
my concern, David, is that there's there might
be a character here that looks like a
valid character.
But but I think I think you're right.
Since he searched them, we we it it
wouldn't have Guy has been in the chat
to confirm there is no Unicode list.
Thanks, Guy.
K.
Shouldn't we look at the maybe it's obvious.
I'm not sure. But should we have looked
at the config for
Sure.
Config?
Maybe that was messed up. Maybe not.
Yes. Well, potentially.
Yeah. It's it would it would have to
be connecting to a different
server. Right? Because because we know we know
that we're getting request to our our instance
of API server from the logs and from
the failures that we're seeing,
don't we?
Is anything, like, off to anyone?
Turn on the what's the hang on a
second. I wanna take a look at
Teleport real quick.
The error that we were getting wasn't able
to get some endpoint.
So Yeah. So and and and because I
did recon.
Another thing that Guy had done previously
was to shut like, mess with Kube controller
manager
to shut down a controller.
I
don't know if Kube API server has anything
like that, but it or or
if that if that could affect this, but
it potentially could. I think I'd still like
to go back and look at the Kube
API server config some more.
So it's failing to watch all of these
resources.
Or if it makes sense to
look at
do do we already look at the containers?
Maybe we should look at that.
Sure.
K. Real before you do that, we we
do l s minus l on these manifests
again.
IT Sploit is asking if the IP is
correct. Yeah. I think we've confirmed that.
So Yeah. Not it.
Can is asking how can I get this
terminal?
It's teleport. Go check it out. Rawkode.live/Teleport.
Naveen noticed an IP mismatch in your admin.com.
That's expected here.
The BGP advertisement address of the control plane
is different from the node itself.
Just a
quick question to if we can do this,
does that mean
that we might have access to other commands?
Or
Potentially. Yeah. So so what what this this
means, like, it is talking to the server.
Right? So we can talk to the server,
which means the server's up and it's running.
That makes it seem like it's permissions, but
I don't know of a way
to deal to to mess with the permissions
in a way that we could like, with
anything like that. But it could certainly be
a flag on Kube API server or something.
Oh, wow.
I'm I'm not sure that it's permissions. I
think a permission error would say something in
in those logs that would be very specifically,
like, cannot get resource because of, like, x
y z, where it's saying, like, failed to
watch,
unable to handle the request, which makes it
seem that the resources that it's trying to
watch might
might not be responding,
or they might not be listening on the
port that we're watching them on,
or they might not be up. So you
will see a lot of those fail to
watch errors and logs kind of all the
time anyway for reasons, but but you're right
about I think you're right about the
the Can I throw something out there? Or
can't hit the new point. What's that? Can
I throw something out there?
Yeah.
So I think we're maybe missing the most
important error message in the logs by using
tail as kinda my hunch. And I think
Okay. It's a d is a problem. If
you remember that first PSU that it's a
d had only been running for three minutes.
Oh,
okay.
And it seems to me that kubectl version
is a sub command that doesn't speak to
it's a d and it's working. So
Mhmm.
Sure.
Where is that? Where is the etcds?
That one. And how long has this one
been running? Can we see notes?
A CUI API server and ITV have been
up for the same amount of time, it
looks like.
Yeah. You might be right, actually.
Let's see the API server logs again.
I said maybe this is a shotgun approach,
but should we look at, like I just
try to spot check the manifest files?
So we only look at the API server.
Right?
I think that makes sense, but but because
we know that we because we know we
can talk to QA API server, I wonder
if there's some other things we could do.
Like, let let's try a a cluster info,
which I know is is
cluster info and component statuses, which is deprecated,
that would be useful, then also get events.
See if either one of those Oh, okay.
Cluster info dump. But is there a way
to, like, filter that so we don't cover
the screen? I think just bot. You don't
even need a dump. Just do cluster info
by itself. It should be done for now.
Okay.
Oh,
yeah. So so I guess we do that.
Yeah. But it's it's it's telling the same
thing. It can't handle the request. Okay. Let's
try the get events.
I I tried that in the beginning. We
can't do that. K.
Server's currently unable to handle the request.
K. Let's check the TD logs.
STD calls are the worst.
True that.
Because no no no one deals with it
all the time. So
okay. So compaction is happening. It seems to
be healthy.
Are we actually
listening on the is that TD listening on
the same port that CUI PI Server is
connecting to? And what what what would that
error look like if if if it couldn't
if CUI PI Server couldn't talk to that
TD?
I think it would make sense if the
error would be something like what we're seeing
where it's not able to process the requests
for, like, watching stuff.
Yeah. Let let let's check those ports and
IP addresses for
the HDD is listening on, make sure that
the writer can leak guys over config.
Do you real quick. Do any of you
guys know the
the reason for the discrepancy? Like, I see
the store index and finished scheduled compaction.
It just happens sometimes, I guess. Maybe because
I'm only tailing the logs.
Yeah. It's because because you're just because you're
telling, but, like, that store index and compaction,
that that happens periodically with FTD as expected.
They know that was, like, triggered by, like,
some action that
is causing our issues. So what should I
check out next?
Let's let's check go see what HTV is
listening on. So let's go check its manifest.
We're going we're gonna look at a couple
of things. We're take a look at those
the the startup probes, libraries probe, the health
probe.
Probably also wanna take a look at it
and then see what HTV is actually listening
on, and then compare what the entity is
listening on to what Kubernetes servers configured do.
Okay. So it's at a 146143
IP address. That's
IP address looks fine.
K. Login's probe is health, not health c,
so we know that's right.
Yeah.
And it is that the right port? Is
it twenty twenty three eighty one?
I believe that's right for TD by default
because it's 2379,
20 3 80, and 2381.
Right? I believe you're right. Yes. Can we
can we can we curl
that that endpoint?
2381?
Yep.
Slash curl.
So the flags you wanna use, if any?
No.
No. I don't think so. There you go.
slash health.
Mhmm.
Great.
Okay.
Let's go back to that manifest.
Alright. So it well, how's how's the readiness
probe look?
There
is no readiness probe. There's liveness in the
start up. Can can you scroll down so
we can look at the start up too?
Start up probe. K.
K. I just wanna make sure it wasn't
the start up probe wasn't set to, like,
something, like,
way in the future, so it wouldn't like,
a super long delay or something, so it
wasn't responding.
Okay.
Well How do we so so, like, the
things that it's saying it can't get, are
they
up? Like,
if we
what are the logs again? It was it
was like
So, like, it it's it's saying it can't
it can't
it's Can't watch these okay.
So it it would be at CD.
Potentially. It it could this
is a tricky one. I I still think
we're we're not seeing enough of those
log.
Yeah.
He's still, like But I I'm I'm stumped.
I've gotta say, I have no idea. I've
not seen this before. Really?
I'm gonna reset my screen again.
K. Just give me so let's just take
a minute. Let just kinda read through these,
see what we
see what's useful here.
Server's currently unable to handle the request.
I wonder I wonder if it's so so
this could be a couple of things. Right?
It it could be search account credentials for
a Kube API server
or
yep. Tilt retrieve.
It's code. Service available.
So how do we confirm whether or not
it's service account credentials or not?
How we how we confirm what?
You said it might be service account credentials?
Yeah. Potentially. So I think we'd wanna go
with a couple of things. We'd wanna take
a look at the
Kube API server manifest again, but we'd also
want let's let's take a look at the
let's it's in Kubernetes PKI
directory
and see if anything there in there has
been changed.
So I'll ask myself.
The Skyscanner team have said, remember there are
hints under slash root if needed. And another
comment from a Skyscan Skyscanner member saying, when
we broke this, we did panic that we
couldn't fix it.
Good job. Well played.
Okay. New solution will want to check out
the API server.
Hold on a second. What was that? What
what was your question, Jeremy?
This is what we want to check the
timestamps and permissions on.
Yeah. Can you also check that SCD directory?
K.
So I think that's interesting. Like, they were
a little panicked that they that they wouldn't
be able to fix it. I'm trying to
think of things that you could do that
you wouldn't be able like,
did did you guys mean, like, you didn't
know if it was possible, or you didn't
know if you would be capable of doing
it if if you had the same problem?
Because those are very different things. Yeah. Let
us know team SkyScanner.
And I do believe based on conversations we
had earlier that they attempted to fix and
that did work. But it's fixable,
but I I think they were panicked. As
far as I know, I could be mistaken.
Do you wanna take a look at the
hint?
I
was so proud of them for not taking
the hint right away. I don't wanna take
it right away either. I wanna keep looking.
Okay.
You've got time. You've got twenty minutes. Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay. So all these that they edited one
of these, like
should we just do, I just renew the
service or something like that?
Sure. Instead of just checking up individually and
because I know there's a change that we
did, and then they just wiped it out
with that. So
Yeah. So I I I so that's that's
certainly true, Jerry, but I will point out
that, like, all these time stamps
are
around the same time, and they're not all
exactly the same. They're, like, within a second
or so of each other or a minute,
which
I think probably means that it was that
they haven't been touched.
I don't trust them. I I think they've
changed something to reset a time stamp on
it. Okay. Can't you do touch star, right,
to reset the time stamp? So so,
David, are we allowed to check the bash
history?
Yeah. I don't think they'll have left, you're
more than welcome to check the bash history.
Let's check it.
Just run history, Jeremy.
Where is this? Does this how yeah. I
don't think you go. Echo Jeremy at the
top, so not useful. Yep.
But good job. Nice try. We we come
we covered our tracks too, but you just
never know. Right?
Is that one cert file supposed to be
five bytes only?
The s a dot s s cert? Yeah.
Are are we able to connect to the
other nodes?
Like, does the API server
see the worker nodes?
We don't know. Right? Because we could do
we did k get nodes, and we don't
we don't get anything. Yeah. Yeah. That's a
good point.
And we and we know Kubla is running.
Right?
Anyone have any prior CTL commands?
What's that?
SkyScout or team are saying nice try on
the history.
People forget to cover their tracks.
I
would still like to go take a look
at the Kubernetes server manifest again
and come and check those IP addresses for
XD and whatnot. This feels like it's permissions
related, though.
But I don't know
I don't know off top of my head
what would cause that. So
there's a couple things. Can I do a
l s dash a l on the manifest?
I'm not sure if that
makes sense to do that. Yeah.
Very good.
We've done that a couple of times already.
Yeah. That's those are the same ish.
Back in this file now. If if you
try to just, like, l s in the
varlogs
containers
like, what containers are are running right now?
Like here?
Yeah. Just wondering.
Okay.
Cool. So we have controller manager. We have
scheduler. We have we know we have FTD
in Cilium
of CUE API server and CUE BIP.
Can we check CUE BIP?
I don't think that'll make any difference.
Sorry. Jeremy, I actually meant the manifest.
Let me see what the manifest is. Oh,
the manifest. Okay.
Yeah.
I have say that the fact that we
are on Teleport via a browser means is
probably okay.
Okay.
If we I stupidly use the BGP advertised
address for Teleport, which I really need to
fix.
But everybody's mentioned that, like, almost every clustered
episode. I know. And then I'm like, I'll
fix it. I'll fix it. I never fix
it. Can
I make another suggestion? Just because this one
is is Yeah. Has piqued my curiosity to
no ends, but I'm gonna suggest you kill
the API server on purpose and catch the
logs from start up. There there has to
be a clue in there.
Yeah. It just feels like like that. There's
there's something we're missing there, and I can't
Yeah. That's a good idea.
Is there supposed to be missing value there
for the one key?
The?
Oh, yeah. Yeah. It looks like there's a
missing missing,
value field for
Yep.
Yep. Yeah. That that's okay. The password is
null, so it's it's acceptable.
Okay. Okay.
Yeah. I I agree with David. Let's let's
let's tail those logs. And and can we
is it possible for us to easily
can can we connect with another session to
to Feel free just to, yeah, open one
on your own site to kill the API
server and leave the logs on the displayed
one. That's that's all good. Okay. I'll do
that. Jeremy, do want me to kill the
logs? Kill the TV API server logs? Yeah.
You'll need to wait for the new pod
ID to come in. So but you you
should be able to get it pretty fast.
Give me one second to get this set
up.
I was gonna do get notes.
K. Done it.
And so Let's take a look at this.
One am I doing?
I
expected a new one, to be fair. Yeah.
Me too.
Did we kill the API server?
Okay. And I should kill minus nine on
the process.
Yeah. So so, Jerry, what what Dave is
asking asking us to do is kill
kill the Kubernetes server, the process, so so
it'll get re so it'll get restarted so
we have fresh logs. Then I'll run a
command so we can maybe
spot where the problem where the problem is.
Just, like, try to give you a a
catch up or something like that. Or Yeah.
API s should be enough.
And so now we're gonna
kill nineteen eighty five.
That's the that's the one we wanna do?
Yep.
Nope. Not that one.
No. No. +1 984 was. But Glad there's
no teleport. Down.
Measure twice, cut once. Oh, you got something
different? PFF. There we go. Okay. Alright. So
are you tailing these logs now? I'm run
a get those command.
Yeah. Tail dash f on that. Just do
tail
yeah. Okay. Just get done here.
You ready?
Yep.
A dash f on that. Sorry. I get
we got a response.
So that worked.
Jeremy,
stop this. Yeah. And just do, hey. Get
notes.
Please. What if it was process 1984 was
the problem?
Okay. Okay. Good luck in everyone. I I
did the quick fix.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Who was expecting that? I wasn't.
So I will say I I wondered about
this kind of thing when because we did
we did something similar with our with our
webhook where, like, you can change a manifest
in some way
to to get it to spin up a
bad process and then change the manifest back
so it doesn't look like it's out of
sync, but it actually is.
Okay. So now
component statuses,
cluster info
I don't really care if a statuses. Right?
I would like to see it. Just curious.
Okay.
Sky scanner are clapping Good.
And seeing I don't saw anything.
Just scheduling control manager, we can ignore that.
It always looks like that. So
I tell you, this this takes me back
to my Windows days. Like, oh, it's broken.
Just restart it.
Turn it off and on and on That's
right. Yep.
Okay. So let's
so we we we talked through, like, some
things to do kinda from the get go.
Can we so we can see let's check
the meeting webhook configurations, routing, or the configurations.
I can type it.
All these shortcuts, and they don't have shortcuts
in it. I don't understand. You you can
hit your auto completion that you that we
created.
Oh, it's validating.
Oh, nope. And it seems to do that.
Hey.
Okay. Alright. Let's delete it. Uh-huh. Delete it.
Uh-huh.
I don't I don't even care what it
was. Just delete it. Well What's up? That's
what I hope they didn't do the kind
of thing that we did too or that
we that we talked about doing, Shahar. So
one thing we talked about doing is putting
a valid webhook in that would replace
the valid webhook configuration.
So I just have one in that would,
like, replace reschedule a replacement.
Oh, I need this part right here. Yes.
I know this. That's a great idea for
future episodes,
actually. Like, have a a broken cluster with
a mutating weapon that fixes new commands. How
do you delete this?
Well, let's go do so just just do
k delete validating webhook configurations dash dash all.
Oh, okay. That's easy.
Cool. There you go. Can I get it
again?
Yep. Cool. Okay.
Cool. So now let's
To the fix? Well, let's update? Let let
I was gonna say let's let's try to
we've got a v two and see what
happens. Yep. I did that deployment.
I suspect we are not done, but Mhmm.
Better now. It's Hey. You don't need to
update it. That's it.
Did we know if it was actually working,
though? Like, did anybody check the web page?
I don't care if it was working.
Yeah. It's like always a good thing too.
Well, because I tried checking it, and then
I'm not sure if I'm using the right
URL, but it's the internal server.
And I can
I can click on applications here, click clustered?
Let's see if he typed in the right.
Work. Right? Yeah. I'll do those. Wonderful. It's
Okay. So let's
so now so now we may be dealing
with an application error. Let's go see make
sure our postcard pod is running.
So I'm gonna check the services and the
pods that are running in the default namespace.
I guess what we're looking for is we
we it's there's no space between the comma
and pods.
Because what we wanna see is we wanna
see if if it's application is all of
its components are up and going.
So it looks like
they are.
Let's check the clustered.
So, David, one thing I didn't notice I
was looking for earlier is is the the
IP address that cluster connects to for Postgres,
is that hard coded in a container?
Yes.
We'll use Postgres
as the DNS name to reach the database.
Cool. Then let's and and with that in
mind, Jeremy, I think we should check core
DNS to see what the core file says.
So
we should be able to get get pods
or get config maps in the Kube system
namespace.
I wanna see that. So I I don't
think they're gonna mess with it. It doesn't
look like, but I would like to see
that core DNS config map.
That's what Guy changed last time for the
record.
I don't think that's would be
So
no. To get oh, yeah. I'm off. Because
we wanna see the I wanna see the
whole thing.
Okay. Hang on a second.
I don't know what that lame duck health
is.
Do you know off top of your head,
David? Is that legit?
No.
And I should know better by now because
I've had to debug Kubernetes many times in
this show, but I
don't. I will point out though that we
got internal server error on the application and
not the DNS error, which would be displayed
to us with angry man from movie.
If so if we if we had
if there were DNS problems, you're the clustered
application would still say It would tell us
that it failed to reach the postgres. But,
I mean, I left a shell in the
clustered pod. You could go ahead and run
a curl if you want to see the
resolution.
You should be able to run bash in
the clustered pod if you wanna confirm.
Yeah. Let's let's The chat is telling us
that lame duck is acceptable and fine. Thanks,
Noel. Cool.
Thank you.
My deal with the cuddle.
One sec in. So cuckuddle exec.
Alright. Just under ten minutes per minute. It's
getting
I'm gonna do that.
Gonna copy it.
Yeah. One thing that I I found myself
trying to do last night was I I
work I do all my work in TMUX,
so when you're messing with things trying to
break it up, I'm trying to do the
TMUX. What is Short prefixes to like, or
something like that? Yeah. Batch is available.
Yep.
So what do wanna do now? You are
in the plug. Yeah. Yeah. Curl
from here. What are we curling again?
Just Postgres.
You just wanna see it resolved.
Yeah. I I kinda wanna see if if
what dig Postgres resolves to.
I know I read dig post search Postgres.
You're gonna have to remember if it's DNS
utils, DNS dash utils, Bange utils.
Yeah.
Okay. So it's it's DNS utils.
I'm getting this utils. You
wanna type it?
Sure.
We've got some support in the chat from
Rawkode saying go team dough.
Mhmm. Oh, got install install. Yeah.
I think it's dash utils.
Is it like that?
I think so.
Yeah. I have to do this every time.
I should really remember it by now. I
would've just googled this by now. It's all
good.
I like to get it wrong 14 times
and then Google it. So
That's right.
There we are.
You always gotta do that update.
It Postgres?
Is that the name of that? Postgres. Service?
Yep.
Okay. So
so it can resolve that.
Let's You have a I'm gonna get that
out here.
I I wanna see I wanna see the
logs.
Like, of the actual application?
Yeah.
Because that might just tell us what the
error is.
Oh, yeah. We didn't run the logs command.
Yeah. There's not a lot logging in the
application, to be fair, but we can see.
Yeah.
Well, thanks, David.
Alright. So we're back in the container now.
Jeremy, I'll let you start driving again.
Alright.
Alright. So
what could this so
we know so we're pretty sure this that
they haven't messed with
the deployment itself.
They might have. Right? So let let's let's
go.
What's what's running here? PSAX.
Okay.
HTTP makes sense.
Let's exit out of this.
That is not my binary for the record.
Okay. Good to know. Let's go let's
let's go take a look at the deployment
again.
Sky scanner. Oh, guy particularly says, you are
doing a great job in getting close.
And Alex confirms he read the Rust code.
There is zero logging in my application.
Oops.
Alright. Let's so I want I wanna check
command line arguments and image name and and
things like that up here.
Matthew says it's written in Rust that doesn't
need logs. I'll translate roughly what he was
saying there. He's right. Memory safety, it can't
crash.
Yeah. So so you so if it can't
crash, you don't need to know what's going
on. Right? Exactly. Right.
Jeremy, can you go can you go to
the top here? Let's go take a look
at the image and the container arguments and
things.
On inside of this Here
we go. What what like,
inside this call or something else?
No. Scrolled up. I want yeah.
For the deployment. There we go. There we
go. Oh, there's a lag. I don't I
don't know.
Oh, yeah. It's lagging. It's crazy, I guess.
Alright. Jeremy,
you you gotta slow down so we can
I'm not I'm not clicking anything. It's just
Oh, sorry. That was me that was scrolling.
No, David. If you could please sabotage us,
we'd appreciate it.
Okay. So
There is? So I'm seeing ghcr.i0
Rawkode clustered v two.
Is that the right image name? That is
well, it's it's the right value for the
image in the YAML. Yes.
Okay. And image pull policy is always.
Let's go check let's go check the service.
Juan, is it possible that I somehow ex
like, left? Oh, now it's updating.
I don't know what's going on. Alright. What
are we checking now?
Let's let's let's check the clusters.
Let's check the clustered service
and the Postgres service as well. But I
think that David gave us a really good
hint with that's not the HBD.
That's Apache. That's not his binary. Binary.
Okay.
I guess I can't do it like that.
If you so you can do so if
you want if you want to determine, you
specify
multiple services with a space between them. So
resource types are comma separated. Resources are space
separated.
So 10.
Uh-huh. 1011112197.
External driven.
Node port,
308080.
And
that was that's for what? That's
This is clustered. What's clustered.
Is it possible that the the service is,
like, only exposing,
you know, that, like, broken maybe, like, Apache
server instead of, like, the regular application?
It certainly is, but but what I'm confused
about is if that's not David's binary
Mhmm. Then how is that what how is
that the thing that's running if we're if
it's actually using his image? So there's an
image pull policy of always.
Presumably,
they didn't somehow get access to the Rawkode
Docker registry,
right, or Docker repository and and replace it
replace it. So how how is it running
the wrong thing? So we go take a
look at the look. Can we go take
a look at the deployment again and check
those arguments?
Because the last time we were doing that,
we got scrolled away from it, and I
think I got distracted.
Alright. So we wanna go take a look
at those arguments, Jeremy,
the image
up in the pod spec or the deployment
pod template.
Yeah. I can scroll it. Yep.
There we go. Alright. I'll just hang out
here for just a minute.
Alright. So clustered GHCR.io,
Rawkode,
clustered v two.
That all looks right. So what's responsible for
pulling that image?
So the image pull policy, but it it's
set to always.
I don't What what actually pulls the image
to the machine?
It's not the Kubit. Container.
Yeah. Container d?
Oh,
okay.
So
I don't I don't know how I I
don't know a lot about container d and
where
things start to
how you can configure everything. Yes. So you
can need the help. You can do a
cryo control images to list the images, and
there's also a super cool command called oh,
you'll need the dash dash runtime endpoint, and
let me take that in for you just
in the interest of time.
Thank you.
Oh, so this is how you avoid the
socket issues that you were having, David?
For container d. Yes.
Yeah. And the other thing I would suggest
is container d space config space dump will
list the container d configuration.
However,
my advice might be getting you colder as
Guy has just said in the chat.
But
I don't know if that's my advice or
what we were doing beforehand.
But I would still take a look at
container deconfig dump before moving on.
Yeah.
I agree.
Alright. So
Although my image isn't listed there, by the
way.
Yeah. No. We're since it's on our worker
machine. Sorry.
Where where's this where's this pod scheduled?
Yeah.
I'll get or something.
Let's see. Or
Dash o y. Yep.
And then we can select the list scheduled
on. Cord cord hey, Jeremy. Cord in the
other two nodes. Delete the pod.
Okay. So I like that.
Which, what what's the cord in command? Is
it, like, core k cord and then the
node? And then the then the node name
show.
Which one do you wanna do? Worker one
or work with two or something? Or I
want I want cord in both of them.
Skyscanner dash worker one and Skyscanner dash worker
dash two.
Okay. So
Is Skyscanner worker dash here? Yep. Mhmm. No.
Space. This is their resources.
So resources are space separated.
Resource types are comma separated.
Remove the comma after the one.
Okay.
And then
something.
You'll need to remove the tint from the
node control plane node.
What is that? Like, get taints or something?
Or You can just do edit node
and just delete the actual yeah. No. We
don't need to do it the nice way.
We could do it through a taint with
a dash syntax, but it's not important.
And control plane.
This is the worker node. Yeah. We we
want to remove the taint from the control
plane.
Those guys gonna dash control. Yeah.
And just search for taint.
In fact, there's there. Top of the spec.
Just No. All the way. Three lanes. You're
right there. Under spec, tanks, the no schedule.
Just remember Oh, yeah. That.
That's
Yep.
K. And what's the next thing you wanna
do? Delete how you want it. Delete that
pod. Yep.
Is that the the clustered one? Or
Yes. No. It's okay. Yes. The clustered one.
Bye bye, broken clustered pod.
I
figure I figure if if if this fixes
it, that's the working around the poll is
as legitimate as Remember a lot. I just
broke from my TD. Right? Right.
Just schedule our workloads on the control plane.
That's funny.
Like, managers are happy.
Just get pods. Oh, no.
I still Jeremy, just getting an internal service
here. Get pods.
Okay. It's still responding to internal server error.
Yeah. It's going to because it's it's Well,
it has to get ready first.
Well, I was thinking if the pod if
the application itself is an option, you would
get a different error besides internal server error.
Yeah. That's that's very possible. So we so
what we're gonna wanna do is go take
a look at that cluster
d service again.
Clustered service.
Alright. I might have made a boo boo.
I think I did call that binary HTTP.
Woah. Alright. I just checked the Docker file
and now I feel awful.
So It's okay.
That's alright. Oh, it's ready now. Okay.
Let's Let's let's hit it. Let's see what
happens.
It's still internal service error? Yeah. That's what
I was saying. Like, the application doesn't need
to be up to get internal server error.
It's probably happening before it hits the application.
Try 30,000.
30 thousand. I'm
sorry. What is it? 30,000.
Oh, So there should be a 30,000. A
node port service
with that.
So so we need to go check the
service again, Jeremy.
Cluster is the name of the service we
wanna check. And not wide. We wanna check
I think you pulled up.
Yeah.
Okay. So
ports, no ports 3,000.
Port eighty eighty. Target ports, eighty eighty.
No endpoints.
K.
Ta da. Let's go check.
Do do do do get inputs just to
make sure. Very
clearly, it seems like that's the case. But
and
show can you show the clustered one with
the YAML?
Alright. I'll give these another five minutes because
of my horrible detour.
So I'm wondering if this is networking. Is
this Cilium?
Are there any network policies defined right now?
Good question. There's a command for that.
I just remember calling it or something. Yeah.
Can you, like, auto complete with network? Oh,
the something happened? Yeah.
All of them?
Okay. So they There's also Selium
versions.
So if you can use the all we'll
complete Selium as well.
I'd also like to after this, also like
to do the the COOP system the pods
in the COOP system namespace again. Let's see
how long this pod's been running.
Oh, it all restarts.
Oh, no.
Is that good or bad? Do dash do
dash o wide on that widget.
So it looks like the Cilium pods themselves
were set up Right. Couple hours ago. Yeah.
That's why I wanna do dash o wide.
I wanna see where those are running. The
guy says you're getting warmer
and remember their sense.
One.
Not
so this is the operator. Right?
So if Jeremy, if if you'll just do
just do that same command but with dash
o wide
so we because I wanna see what nodes,
the Cilium.
Rawkode two?
No. No. That coop get get pods dash
in coop system dash o wide. I just
wanna see what nodes the Cilium pods are
working on. Oh, okay. Because because Cilium
start with restarted not
too long ago. Restarted not too long ago.
Mhmm.
Let's go let's go check let's
go check the Cilium configuration for that daemon
set.
Yeah. So
You wanna do, like, get a YAML? Or
Yeah.
Kube system.
Yeah. You're gonna have to dash in the
Okay.
And
we're gonna need to see this whole thing.
So let's go let's start from the top.
Oh, wow. Okay. So this was reapplied,
at least once.
Generation seven.
Keep going down?
Yep.
That's what what I'd probably do is I
just scroll down the page and and let's
stop right there and take a look. So
we have a so we're gonna need to
take a look at that Sicilian config map.
So you want to Yeah. Yeah. Look at
that?
Not yet. Both config maps. Okay. Going. Yeah.
Actually, I kinda get get get in our
heads, like, the things we need to go
look at. So, obviously, we wanna check widens
probes and
readiness probes. I
don't think that's gonna be an issue.
K.
This is the kind of thing it's gonna
be hard to spot if it's in here.
What's that? Hold on.
I don't
where were you? I think go
down. No. Right there. That volume out that
mount path host host PID,
is that one n s? Is that right?
I don't know.
Where?
Right here.
Under volume mounts, mount path.
I just highlighted it. I'm waiting for it
to show up on okay. There it is.
Yeah.
So slash host has mounted into these pods,
but I don't know. I don't think that
the host pad one MSS. I don't maybe
we should take a look at the mode
definition.
I like it.
We enter volumes.
Oh, yeah. There we go.
Do you see it?
Not yet.
Volume outs or volumes?
So go go back into volume outs so
we can Oh, there it is. What we're
looking. It's the third one.
What's that?
Oh, yeah.
It's right there. Yeah. So so, certainly, host
proc NS
is is legit. Right? So then it's just
mounting it into host PID one NS.
So I suspect it's right. Can we can
we search this for host PID one NS?
You might you might need to do an
edit just so you can search in VIM.
I mean, the pod is running.
If the mounts were in correct,
we'd probably get an error when the container
was starting.
Yeah.
Is this too many?
The host pet one
n s.
Oh, okay.
Host pet
one One n s. N s. Yes.
K.
That's not Okay. Go on. Oh,
hit in to go to the next one.
Alright. Should we take a look at a
couple of the hints and get this? Yeah.
Yeah. Yep. I think it's probably time.
What do guys think? You wanna hint?
Think so.
Sure.
I wonder if DNS policy is something too.
So where's the hint? In the root? Slash
root. Yep.
Let's do hinge one, I suppose.
Oh, thanks for the red herrings. I think
that sometimes you need to call IT.
What is the So turn something off and
back on.
That was that was what? The cubelet with
the API server that we did?
Yep. Okay.
Oh, there's a link. Alright.
Did it recrawl?
Think he's Oh, nothing. That's
just just the API server hunt.
Yep.
Yeah. I think you've worked that out. We
know it's networking. Yep.
Wonderful. Okay. So I don't I'm I am
not a Cilium expert. I've I've haven't done
much with it.
So Chirp. The component they're talking about
do you want me to say something, or
is Shahar a Cilium ninja here? Like I
I do not know what it would be.
Oh, so
well, so Cilium can can be set up
to to replace, like,
all of the
the the networking,
I guess I guess, DNS, couldn't it?
So I think you're talking about Kube
proxy.
Kube proxy. That's right. Say, let's let's check
the config. The config maps for Celia.
Yeah.
It's gonna be in the Kube system namespace,
Jeremy.
There we go. There you go. And so
this should just be a flag that allowed
me to do that?
Stop.
What's cube monkey config map?
There is the cube monkey pod running as
well. I wasn't sure if you noticed the
earlier.
Okay. I'm assuming that's not a
Yeah. So that's probably the one I think.
Think we're gonna need to so I think
we're gonna need to a look at Cilium
config to figure out what what's happening there
because we're probably gonna have to put Cilium
fix Cilium config,
and then we might have to delete KubeMonkey
config mapping. We need to play the.
Alright.
Look look for KubeMonkey in here, would you?
I would do an edit on this just
so that we don't have to scroll. Yep.
And then
about cube proxy replace?
It was set to disabled.
Okay.
Did we have a Kube proxy running in
the Kube system namespace?
I don't think it's a question.
What
am I taking again? Is it
pods pods and KubeSystem. Okay. Now
we have KubeMonkey.
Oh.
We we just
so let's that so that KubeMonkey is a
deployment. Let's just delete it in its config
map because it shouldn't be running. I don't
know what it is, but that seems very
highly suspicious.
Or actually, don't let's not delete no. Let's
not delete the pod. Let's edit the deployment
scale to zero. That way we don't if
if it is necessary for something, we don't
lose it.
So just do two. So this is least
you can do.
Yep. That'll work.
And what are we editing?
Replicas. So you said the scale? Oh, zero.
Got it. Scale it down. Yeah. Scale is
DOCC. Replicas is the the
Kubernetes name for that.
And then we'll do this guy.
Something should have happened. Right?
Yeah.
So you're probably going to want to turn
on the cube proxy replacement
because we have no cube proxy, so there's
no custom networking.
Right.
So should that be enabled then? There are
two potential values. There's probe and there's strict.
I would go with probe.
What what do those do, David?
Probe allows us to do checks to see
if it should be taken over, and I
think strength enforces
it to run and do e b p
f routing.
I can't remember exactly, but I think that's
correct.
We we we
the cluster that I work on mostly use
Cooper routers, so I haven't done much of
Cillium.
You'll need to do a rollout of the
Cillium
pods.
But there was a keen eye comment from
Noel in the chat suggesting that they noticed
this Celium deployment was actually mounting the monkey
config map. So you may wanna Oh. Check
that too. Okay.
Go to Celium deployment and
let's edit that out. And the cube system
namespace.
The
Cilium deployment. Yeah?
The I think it'd be the Cilium operator.
Nope. So we were looking at the Cilium
daemon set, and we searched for monkey who
didn't see it.
Yeah. So I would just
edit the demon set,
change any value, or do a a rollout
because you need you need it to pick
up that.
The silly one right here?
Yeah.
Alright. So search for monkey again, would you?
Noel has retracted his statement.
Guy. Well, there might not be a monkey,
but just make an artificial change to to
rotate those pods over and see if we
get. The
if we can't call 30 our networking isn't
working.
So an artificial change, what what would that
be?
Just add a new label. Yep.
What? Add a new label.
So under the template There we go. Yep.
Nope. No. No. No. Not that. That's not
gonna do it. You have to go down
to the spec templates
labels. Just add a label underneath. See where
it says labels? Just a few lines down
from where from there. It says k h
a. Just add an additional label.
Right.
Yeah.
It's called
there you go.
I can just put a null or something.
It doesn't matter. Yeah. Empty string will work.
And we should see those pods moving.
Yep. I
mean, we could also have done a control
rollout restart demons at the end, but who's
got time for that?
I'm more of a delete pods dash dash
all kind of person.
Too.
Yeah. You could probably try local host and
see
if that's working.
Yep.
Oh, look at that. That's bear.
Right?
There we go. Oh, yeah. It's up.
Cool.
Go to the go to the cluster. Oh,
Stay the skirt. Oh, that's good. Very nice.
Finally. We got to use the hints. I'm
glad.
It's all good. Actually, I don't think you
I mean, we read the hints, but I
think you were already there. Like, you were
you were ahead of the hints. Like, none
of the hints were surprising to you. Right?
So Right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. This is fun. Two
tough clusters. Thanks. Damn. Thank you, Skye. I
think breaking is a little a little easier,
but
Alright. Well, thank you so much for joining
me. It was great watching you as well.
Thanks for having us. I'm glad we we
stuck with that. We were so close for
for a while there. I'm really, really sorry
for leading you down the HTTP binary.
I'm gonna kick myself for that. That makes
it more realistic. That's how it works in
production for real.
I think it was great.
Alright. Well, thank you again. Have a wonderful
evening. Enjoy your weekend. Thank you to all
of our viewers for watching.
Thank you to Teleport for sponsoring. We will
be back next week. Thanks all.
Bye, everyone. Bye all.